FAISAL ABID: All right.
Everyone hear me well?
Good, awesome.
Thank you for
coming after lunch.
I know everyone
just wants to sleep.
So do I. So "From Zero to One--
Building a Real World
Flutter Application."
What you'll learn about
me throughout this talk
is I'm super lazy.
I'm so lazy that I took
the title of the talk
from that Peter Thiel book.
And so I'm, like, whatever,
I just need a good title--
"From Zero to One."
So this talk is really about me
building a real world Flutter
application in record time--
really, five days.
And the application is
actually pretty big.
It has about 500,000 users.
And so I said, let's
build it in Flutter.
And we'll find out why and how
I built it really quickly--
because I'm lazy.
I use a lot of libraries.
So yes, I just talked
about the first part.
Second part is the
architecture of the app.
I'm going to spend about
two minutes on it, just
a high level overview
of how the app looks.
And then we'll go
through each section
and talk about the tips
and tricks I learned
from building that
specific section
and, really, which
libraries to use.
So about me.
This is my funniest
scene, who am I?
I don't know.
So who am I, really?
I'm a Google Developer
expert in Dart and Flutter.
I've been doing Dart
for a long, long time.
I think I started Dart
probably like two years after--
or a year after--
it was released,
mainly because I was tired
of just doing web stuff,
and I just wanted to
do something else,
aside JavaScript.
And I really started
Dart from the server.
And I started using Dart
on the server a lot--
built this app in 2015, or
2014, in Dart, on the server.
And it was really good, so I
just fell in love with Dart--
started doing it on
the web, eventually,
and then, now, with Flutter.
I've been-- you know I wrote--
anyone read Flutter for
Android on Flutter.io?
Yes-- one, two.
That was me.
I wrote that in,
like, two months.
So if you find spelling
mistakes, that's on me.
I've been an Android developer
for a long time, which
is very relevant,
because Flutter
is a much better experience
for me as an Android developer.
I've been doing Android since
M1, when Android didn't even
have a keyboard,
believe it or not.
So you just had to
have a hardware device.
Anyone remember the G1 device?
Yes.
Yeah, this is Google--
I'm sure.
Obviously, you guys built it.
And then.
I'm also a Senior
Engineer at Zoom.ai.
This is what I do
during the day.
So I do a lot of things.
I don't know how I have
time for any of this.
Zoom.ai is an AI-based
automated assistant.
That's all I'm going to
say about that for now.
And outside of work,
I'm an entrepreneur,
trying tons of different ideas.
And this is why
Flutter is also good.
I do a lot of mobile apps.
I do a lot of web
stuff, backend stuff.
And Dart and Flutter just help
me make stuff really quickly,
try it out.
Fail a million times.
Get rich off a couple of them.
So the one that made
some money is Ven Chat.
I started it in 2015.
It's one of the top 150
to 200 grossing apps,
depending on the month.
It's very variable.
It has half a million installs.
It's essentially a
chat app for singles--
there's nothing
special about it--
and it's built in Android
currently, with a Dart backend.
And so where does
Flutter fit into this?
Well, every time I look at stats
on apps making money-- anyone I
talk to in the industry--
they're always talking,
telling me about how iOS
is making a lot more money.
Any app published in iOS
makes two times, three times
the money.
So I wanted to build an iOS app.
The problem is I
don't have time.
I have a day job.
And I come home, and
I work on this stuff,
or I'm trying new stuff.
And I don't want
to build an iOS app
and then maintain
two apps all at once.
Because not only do I spend
three months building an iOS
app, then I've got to spend the
rest of the app's life cycle
maintaining new features in
iOS, maintaining new features
in Android--
doing the same thing
over and over again.
It's a nightmare.
I don't want to do that.
That's how I feel whenever
I thought about doing iOS.
And then Swift came
along, and I'm like, hmm,
maybe I'll do Swift.
Then I looked at it again,
and I'm like, no, forget that.
I'm not doing that.
So Flutter became the
obvious choice for me.
A lot of people
say, well, you know,
you still have to
write two apps.
I'm like, yeah.
But then I can use
iOS as a guinea pig--
test the app on there--
test the Flutter up on iOS--
get all the bugs hammered out,
all the usability, whatever.
And then just file
build on Android
and get it published there.
So it's a very seamless process.
I don't want to touch my
revenue stream on Android.
So it makes sense for me to
build an iOS Flutter app,
test it out, and deploy.
So that's how I feel I'll be
after I deploy the iOS app.
So it just got submitted to
Apple for approval yesterday.
Should be in stores soon.
So let me give you a quick
demo of how the app is--
very simple.
What I did for the demo is--
because it's a chat app,
I replaced all the pictures
with randomuser.me,
and I recorded a video.
I recorded a video here.
All right, so here's the app.
And this is all in Flutter.
So this is running on iPhone
X, or via simulator iPhone X.
And I'm just going to-- it's
like a 40 second preview.
You can scroll.
There's a bunch
of people there--
that crazy guy over there.
I can see the new members
that just recently joined.
And then I can see a
list of all people that
have sent me a message.
I can click on a person--
for example, this
person right here--
and send them a message.
Right?
Simple, and that's about it.
And so when I ended up building
this, the app was roughly 60%
less code than Android.
It does a lot, especially for a
single developer just building
this in his free time.
It was a lot less code.
That's mainly because Flutter
just makes everything so much
easier.
Building list views
on Android, you've
got to build up an adapter,
set up recycling, or doing
all sorts of crazy stuff.
On Flutter, I just pass
in an array into a list,
and I'm good to go.
And it really took me five days.
After all that procrastination,
I'm like, you know what?
I finally need to build this.
I sat there, started building
it, and within 15 to 20 hours,
I was done--
five after-work days, so
that's like two hours a day
or something, and I was done.
That was me for a couple
of days, working away.
And the architecture is
pretty simple for the app.
We have a Websocket
that comes in,
and that's really for all
the chat realtime stuff.
We're not using
Firebase for realtime.
That's because when
you send a message,
it used to go to our server, do
a lot of spam analysis on it--
tons of moderation
and everything--
and then we send it to the user.
And so we use a
Websocket for that.
The Websocket then triggers
an event bus message,
which is when you're
chatting with a member,
a message comes in.
You can start replying
to the member.
And then, also, as you
chat, your points go down.
So there's an in-app currency.
You have a finite
amount of points
before you have to buy
more points to track.
And so the points are also being
pushed by Websocket, every--
whenever you send
a message or when
someone sends a message to you.
And then, lastly, there's
a complicated REST API.
There's like 40, 50 endpoints
there doing all sorts of stuff,
from uploading pictures
to videos, audio clips,
creating profiles,
downloading tons of data--
lots and lots of stuff there.
So I'll go through each
one of these pieces,
and talk about the
challenges I face
and how I solved
it in record time.
The first one is Websockets.
Like I said, Websockets allow
realtime chat between the user,
the server and the user again.
The problem was Websockets need
to be opened during the app.
But when the app is
in the background,
I need Websockets to stop.
So on Android and iOS, there's
an on-resume, on-pause callback
done.
On Android, at least, I
used a Websocket stop.
And then on the
on-pause and on-resume,
I did websocket.start.
I wanted to find something
similar in Flutter,
and I did, thanks to
WidgetsBindingObserver--
if everyone can see that code.
The slides will be
up later too, but I'm
going to quickly describe it.
WidgetsBindingObserver
is a way for you
to listen to your
application states,
and this was perfect for me.
So what I did was I set up
a WidgetsBindingObserver
at the top level of my app.
That's the only place I need
this Websocket to start,
because the rest of it
is handled by event bus.
And I set that up--
I set up an instance in the init
state, and then I get rid of it
when you're disposing
of the estate.
And then in did application
lifecycle change,
I just detect, hey, is the app
open, or is the app closed?
The super simple architecture
pattern that I found
was super easy for me to
just turn on the Websocket
and turn it off.
And the big thing is it helps
me conserve battery life.
Because if I keep the Websocket
running in the background,
you just have an
open socket going,
and it's just going to eat
up the person's data and also
the battery life.
So WidgetsBindingObserver
is a really useful trick
if you have something long
running that you want to pause
when the application
goes in the background.
The second is points are an
in-app currency in the app.
Like I said before,
whenever you do something,
points are being used.
Now, the points are
actually shown everywhere
throughout the UI.
If you browse the
app a lot, you'll
see that everywhere you
go, you'll see points,
and how many points you have.
And those points
are always being
updated, depending on your
interactions with the app.
And so my initial pattern there
was build a simple event bus.
On every widget-- every page--
I have an event bus that's
listening to the points.
And then when you go off the
page, I close the event bus,
and I listen to it
again on the next page.
It seemed too messy.
There had to be an easier way.
And so I started digging
through the documentation,
and I found this great thing
called InheritedWidget.
An InheritedWidget is a simple
way to pass a piece of data
across all your
widgets without having
to set up a bunch
of event listeners,
without having to call a set
state whenever data is updated.
And so what I did was I
set up an InheritedWidget
at the root of my widget
tree, at the start.
And then that passed in
points, and all I had to do
was just have one event bus
listener for points coming in
from my Websocket.
And that just sent
out an update that
propagated throughout the
app whatever was active,
and the points got updated.
So code sample there is
here's my points widget,
really simple.
I just extend InheritedWidget.
All the constructor takes is the
actual points that the user has
at this point, and then a child.
And the child, in my case,
is the entire application,
and then it should
notify update.
When should the InheritedWidget
notify its children
that there has been an
update to the points?
When the points are not
the same as the new points.
Simple logic there.
And then I just wrote a simple
helper function called Of,
which takes in a context and
searches through the widget
tree to find where
this points widget is.
And that's how I get a
handle to this widget.
Then I set it up in my
application at the top there.
So this is my main.dart file.
I call new points
widget, pass in points.
There's some code
above it that's
just actually listening
to the Websocket
and getting the
points coming in.
And then there's my material
app, which is the child there.
After that, somewhere, anywhere
in my app in the widget tree,
I can call--
if you notice
pointswidget.ofcontext.points.
And wherever I'm
listening to that--
whenever points are updated--
that's going to trigger
an update on that widget,
and I'll get the most recent
points that the user has.
This is really useful because
it helps you save memory state
also, rather than
opening tons of listeners
and then forgetting
to close them.
That's a problem
that I kept running
into where I kept forgetting to
cancel the stream subscription,
and I kept running into widgets
being updated in the background
and causing all sorts of issues.
So InheritedWidget
is your friend.
Use it for when you want
to pass a piece of data
across the application.
It seems daunting.
The docs aren't
super clear on it.
But if you take a
look at the sample--
and there's a great
medium post on it too--
you'll understand that it's
actually a very simple concept,
and you can really
use it anytime
you want when you have a
single piece of data flowing
through your application.
Now, once I had these
two things going,
my next big challenge
on Android was--
I use Retrofit.
Anyone here use Retrofit before?
Yes.
OK, great.
Lots of Android guys here.
So Retrofit, for those
that haven't used it,
basically takes the JSON
and converts it into a POJO.
Awesome.
There's nothing
like this on Flutter
that I found, mainly
because Flutter
doesn't have reflection.
And so the big
problem there was I
had so many endpoints
and so many data types.
I'm a lazy developer.
I did not want to write down
all these single data types over
and over again, and build
out a fromJSON and toMap,
and all sorts of
crazy stuff there.
So I started digging, and I
found this great library called
Jaguar Serializer.
Anyone here used this before?
No.
Perfect.
No one knows about this
library, and I don't know why.
This is awesome.
So what Jaguar
Serializer does is--
here's a simple code snippet.
I have a message class.
Message is just
a simple object--
a simple PODO, as
I like to call it.
And all I'm doing
here is I'm annotating
that this should be generated.
And I override the
toMap, and I fill out
what it should be
when it converts
into a map, when I'm actually
sending it back to the server.
And then in my pub spec,
I enter Jaguar Serializer
version 0.5.1, and I install the
command line tool, Jaguar CLI.
I run it and it automatically
generates the actual Dart
file, with all the fromJSON
and toMAP stuff done for me.
And so this is how I use it.
I call it http.get.
This is me making a
request for a conversation,
passing a conversation ID.
When the message comes in,
I take the response body,
I convert into a map, and I do
serializer, right into a PODO.
And it works really well.
And so now I just have a message
object that I can pass around
my app, versus
having a map and then
converting that into
a message object
and then doing the
painful conversion back.
So use it.
It's a must.
I think it's like the
de facto thing you
have to use in a Flutter
app because you're
always almost going to be
using JSON, unless you're crazy
and you use XML.
And so this is the best
thing to use there.
Now, this is a common
little widget pattern
that I developed in the app.
And this is just like a quick
tip in the app, and which is--
a lot of places, I'm
using Gesture Recognizer.
I think almost everyone here is
using Gesture Recognizer to do
taps or drags and stuff.
What I found is I don't want
to keep creating a new Gesture
Recognizer and have a big
syntax there-- passing a child,
create a function and stuff.
So as well with dialogs,
you do Show Dialog,
then you have a really
complicated-- not complicated--
but a big enough method call
to create an actual dialog.
So what I did was--
because Flutter widgets are
these immutable lightweight
widgets, I just stuck
them into a static class
I call common widget utils.
And what I do there is I
have widgetutils.addclick,
Chose and addclick takes
in a widget and a function.
It shouldn't be called
container, actually.
It should just be
a normal widget.
And then here, I just
create a Gesture Recognizer.
So this really streamlines
my development, where
I can just do addclick,
pass in the two parameters,
and I'm done.
Same thing with show dialog.
You can see that a dialog
takes in a lot of stuff there.
All I do is create
dialogue, pass
in a context and the actual
message I want to show,
and that's it.
I don't need a complicated
widget tree in my file there.
Next, once I started
doing all this stuff,
I needed to deal with routing.
The app has a lot of pages.
The demo-- I only
showed two pages,
but the app is very deep.
There's galleries, and
videos, and rating--
all sorts of crazy stuff.
And so I needed a
good routing system.
Flutter's routing
system is good,
but it doesn't make it
easy to pass data through.
Coming from Android, all
I do is I take a bundle,
and I just pass in a bundle.
I look at the other
app, and then I
can extract that bundle there.
It doesn't make it easy.
So I looked into the
docs, and I found
that you have to use
onGenerateRoute and parse
in the argument yourself.
I'm lazy.
I'm crazy.
I don't want to do that.
And so I found a great
library called Fluro.
And Fluro is built on top
of Flutter's routing system.
What I like about it-- it
has these function handlers
that actually pass
in the arguments
that I pass in the route.
So then I can take
those arguments,
and I can convert them--
or pass them-- into my state.
I'll show that
example in a second.
And so that's Fluro.
That's the cool logo there.
And you can see that
I have a routes class.
And, basically, Configure
Routes has tons of routes.
In this example, I
just have a chat route,
and it takes a chat
handler function.
And then the chat
handler function
creates a new widget--
new chat screen--
and takes in the name,
ID, and the conversation
ID so that when I want to
start chatting with a member,
I click on member's profile,
and all of these arguments
are passed in.
And the way I call
this, let me see--
where is it?
OK, the way you actually
call it is simple.
You just call navigator.push
and pass in the arguments,
as you would in a website.
Like, we were doing
angular development
or any sort of web development
as query parameters.
And they'll get parsed
into a bundle there.
That's where I actually create--
you configure your
routes at the start.
That's just some
sample code there.
All, right so Fluro--
use it.
It's a must.
I find it extremely
useful, and that's
like the best routing available.
The next part that I
ran into was images.
They're a big part of
the app, obviously.
There's images everywhere.
But I needed something
that was robust.
I just didn't need something
that tried to load an image,
didn't cache it,
and then just died
if the mobile network
wasn't working,
or the person's on
2G or something.
And so I didn't
want to write this.
Again, I'm lazy.
I started looking.
And I found something written
by the Flutter team, actually,
called Flutter Image.
And it's called Network
Image with Retry.
And what Network Image with
Retry does is it takes a =
and it tries to fetch the URL.
If it fails, it does
some algorithm there
to try to fetch it again,
depending on what's happening
with network conditions.
And it returns an
image provider.
Now that you have
an image provider,
you can take Network
Image with Retry
and pass it into a circle
avatar declaration--
wherever you want.
You can take this and
just pass it there.
So at the bottom
there, you can see
that I have a container with
a center in it and a circle
avatar.
And you saw there was a bunch
of circle pictures there,
and that just takes
in a background image.
Then I have a helper class
called getProfilePic,
which-- at the top
there-- returns
a Network Image with Retry.
So real simple-- and then I
just have a robust image caching
and retry solution.
Use it.
Another quick tip that I found--
in the app, in the Android
app, I had a lot of small--
not small--
fairly lengthy but
plain old Java logic.
It wasn't using anything
Android specific.
It was just a lot of DRM and
some calculations of stuff
that needs to be done.
And so I didn't really want
to write them in Dart, mainly
because they were so long.
So being lazy, I searched Java
to Dart converter on Google.
And I did find something.
I found Java to Dart web.
I can actually show
you guys an example.
And basically you pass in--
let me increase there--
you pass in some Java, and
you get some Dart back.
And this really
helped me just pore
over a lot of
legacy, old Java code
to Dart easily, just
copying and pasting in.
Don't try to pass in,
like, actual Android code.
It most likely won't work.
But it's a quick little tip.
It'll be in the slides after.
Now, this was a big one, and
I'll show the demo of the app
again for this.
But a responsive UI--
when I click on anything in the
app, it makes a network call.
Network calls are slow.
It doesn't matter where
you are on your phone--
I mean, where you are
location-- sometimes,
it will just be slow.
Sometimes, your
server might be slow.
And you just don't want
to show a white page.
So you want to show
a progress bar.
The way you do that currently
in Flutter is you have a show
loading equals false.
And if show loading is false
in your build function,
you show a spinner animation.
Else, you show your
entire widget tree.
Now, I didn't want to write
that over and over again,
so I started finding
a solution for it.
And so what I came across
was this great library
called Async Loader.
Anyone here use this library?
Great.
Look at this-- all this crazy
information no one's used.
So Async Loader is actually
probably the most amazing
FLUTTER library I've seen.
And this is how you use it.
You create an async loader
in your build function.
And it has a few
parameters there.
It has init state, render
load, render error,
and render success.
Init state is, basically,
as the widget is floating,
what do you want to load?
What data do you want to load?
As render load is as
it's being loaded,
what do you want to show?
So in render load, I
show a progress bar.
Render error is if
something went crazy wrong,
what do you want to do?
So here, for the
sake of the demo,
I just have new text error
loading conversation.
So you see a boring old
error loading conversation
on the page.
What you typically want is some
sort of nice little graphic
that says, oh, something went
wrong, please press back.
And then finally, when
all your data is loaded,
render success is
called with your data
that you return in
your init state.
And then you can take that
data, and then you can actually
render your entire UI.
So here, in the video--
let's go back here.
So when I click this, if you
see, that's this loading bar.
That's actually a
show progress loading.
And then it loads and loads.
And then once that
load is done, it
calls render success
with all my data,
and then there is my entire UI.
So it really gives me a nice
little abstraction for--
yeah, it gives a nice
level abstraction away,
rather than having this
if sort of logic inside my
build function.
And then I just take
the Async Loader--
I pass it to my scaffold,
and you're done.
So use it.
Lastly-- so I mean, with all
this done, my app was amazing.
I was able to build
it in like five days.
And then I sent it to
Apple for approval,
and then they'll probably
get back three months later.
And so I rewrote my entire app.
It was really painless.
Because I wrote it
so quickly-- you
have to understand
that I actually
had a lot of the app built. I
had the API already written.
I had all the interfaces,
the logic, there.
So in a real world
application that if you're
writing from scratch, you can
probably get a real Flutter
application done in a
week or more, actually,
but nothing too crazy
like a couple of months.
And my strategy there
is to launch iOS first.
Test it.
Launch Android after all
the testing, and then
just delete the Android project.
Because whatever.
Now I can maintain one app, and
I can make money through it.
And that's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]